check out this week let people I chose  the life in some way  it's going to get me count Charlie  Sauron stars in atomic blonde of an  undercover agent who goes to Berlin on a  deadly mission during the Cold War come  on I think I love you  welcome to the world inside your phone  in the emoji movie family fun awaits as  a specially gifted emoji seeks to become  a normal emotion maybe and men have more  than just one emotion nor get stronger  and more destructive this is global  warming  Al Gore returns in an inconvenient  sequel a documentary that revisits the  issue of climate change worldwide this  is our home see what's hot in theaters  with this week anticipation  [Music]  what's your weekend ticket going to be  let us know by commenting see you next  time on weekends ago  you  [Music]